so these two kids are
noteworthy because
this brand kruger which is from newark
new jersey was the very first brewery
ever to test market the beer can back in
1935 and they really didn't know how
this was going to go they thought this
might just sort of be a fad they thought
it might completely flop
they they really didn't know
but they found very quickly that their
marketing in the new cans worked really
well people were totally into it they
loved the convenience of it
there were a lot of advantages to having
beer in cans first of all they took up
less space
you could just simply throw them away
when you're done with them you didn't
have to return empties
they weren't breakable
like
the glass bottles
you just get a lot more product in your
refrigerator
it was much more efficient
way of getting the product to the to the
consumer and as you can see here they
also have how to open the can
right on the label and this is the
little
church key opener that would have been
used to open the top of the can
[Music]